oh man I declare sinuses
oh I can smell everything
[Music]
hey what's going on and Happy
Thanksgiving everybody for first week
Feast I'm Sean Evans and you're watching
hot ones it's the show with hot
questions and even hotter wings and
today we're joined by Israel adesanya
he's one of the UFC's most accomplished
and dominant Fighters having previously
defended his middleweight championship
belt five times sure he may walk in
today's interview with a professional
record of 23-2 but how will he Fair
going the 10 round distance with the
wings of death I guess only time will
tell israelisanya welcome to the show
thank you for having me so you did an
episode of Truth or dab about a year ago
with Anthony Joshua and basically bodied
our spiciest Wings how confident are you
going into today's challenge
um that was then and this is now I just
had a fight like two days ago so
yesterday I found out
um through having a spicy chicken
sandwich that I might have some cuts
under my tongue or around my tongue so
yeah we'll find out are you ready to get
started ready bro let's go
foreign
[Music]
let's go cheers
you always have to wait for like the
surprise kicker that's someone who's
been around yep part two or party but
this is like there we go
[Music]
I'm actually hungry
so my voice still hasn't fully recovered
from Saturday night's event at Madison
Square Garden yeah went to the fight
took the team yeah and I know it wasn't
the result that you were looking for but
it was still just an epic fight epic
performance and with today being
Thanksgiving the line that you had in
your post fight press conference about
being grateful really stood out to me
what is it that you're grateful for and
why do you Embrace moments like these no
matter the outcome okay it's still good
but I just got like the part two
um what am I grateful for yeah
Just A Moment Like just seeing looking
around and seeing a lot of kiwis other
people from back home I didn't even get
to go to Times Square because I can't
really go to Times Square like I I used
to and my face is plastered on the
[ __ ] screens and in Madison Square
Garden I did something is in headlights
and yeah so I'm just grateful for these
moments and grateful for the opportunity
grateful for the life I live the because
I mean I it wasn't it wasn't long ago
but I still remember like you know
I get five books on number number seven
at the gas pump that kind of stuff so
now yeah being in the situation you just
have to be grateful for everything The
Good the Bad the Ugly the Beautiful
Everything
if I start speaking in tongues forgive
me
what's the one that one of my favorites
is um Khalid oh yeah if I quit
I like that
that's mentality you can see that you
understand that you're playing 3D chess
like Khaled facts 40. it's not even here
we're up there
so far so good looks like you're
enjoying the wings I'm hungry man I can
see that but I'm trying to lie okay let
me save myself yeah and I don't want
Nigerian like this is even like
appalling it's the first wing and this
is appalling my culture right you got to
represent this should me
like a cartilage all that
what would you say was your greatest
press conference bar like you seem to
approach these things almost as a rapper
with a cipher my favorite was the
ignoramus
buffoonista what's my favorite one let
me see
um I think nosebleeds to nosebleeds is
classic yeah I love that and actually
funny enough today might be the
anniversary actually so today eight
years ago I believe I was in Melbourne
back then Etihad Stadium well I watched
um Ronda Rousey versus Holly Holm from
the nosebleeds and I saw Robert Whitaker
fight there against Uriah Hall
and then how many years later I fought
in the same Arena now Marvel Stadium
and I told him back then I was in the
nosebleeds and I'm gonna make his nose
bleed yeah and I did what I made his
nose bleed
bars are you ready to move on here to
round number three I like how you get me
comfortable there we go we're having a
good time it's just a barbecue little
fake leaves all that
we have to cookout we're at the cookout
let's go
[Music]
I like how he looks at you before he
takes a bite it's like he's trying to
like I'm sizing you up yeah exactly I
can feel the energies
[Music]
let's see how you going this is my face
down you know this is my scare down it's
elephant welcome to my Arena welcome to
my Arena this is like every every week
every week a psychopath for like eight
years I know you know Dan hooker right
yeah he's a tree you got to get him on
here
so he thought um this really good
Fighter the Phenom what's his name the
Peruvian Prince I can't remember his
name forgive me
I'd send the kids yeah on Saturday and
the kid is known for like leg locks they
kept trying to get down there they kept
trying to bring them both front when he
finally got it
I if I recall I go to Anchor lock
and then
he got like a knee bar and he just like
cranked and I remember the guy's face
like
[Music]
raping you see Dan just sitting there
like
his leg got like literally his leg being
hyper extended
and Dan's just sitting there hit him in
the body a few times and the guy's there
like cranking for his life for maybe
about 10 seconds and the guy goes
but this guy and Dad's sitting there
just like
[Music]
cool this is a psychopath that's how
he'd be on this show just whatever sauce
he's white as well so you know he's
gonna go right
but he's a psychopath he'll endure he's
his fortitude
I don't understand like spicy food he
lived in Thailand yeah oh yeah yeah some
Foundation there he'll be fine yeah he
lived in Thailand for a while
[Music]
I'm waiting for that bit where that
music comes on okay I can smell this one
you know I bet when it's like boom oh
yeah
that like Airy music yeah
call that a little metal on metal that's
what I call that we call that one the
scrape yeah the scrape yeah that's what
I'm waiting for
eign how
it's holding up a problem or not a
problem there we go
I'm glad I came here hungry so maybe
that makes me want to attack these more
there I can see it yeah so I'm actually
fascinated by New Zealand's King in the
ring event a single illumination
kickboxing tournament that sounds like
something straight out of a Jean-Claude
Van Damme movie can you pull back the
curtain on what that event is like from
a Fighter's perspective having to go
back to back to back in a matter of
hours for a title very good question
so
um
when you do King in the ring right you
have to fight if you win three times in
one night or if you come second
um when you have one fight even if it's
kickboxing
three minute rounds three rounds after
the fight guess what happens you get an
adrenaline dump okay
so I'm glad I had people in my corner
like Doug mining who's one of our
coaches
shout out to Doug
but one thing he said early on that
night is like you only have one fight
because if you don't get that fight done
they're gonna fight some exist and that
has always stuck with me and
a bunch of flex as well so King of the
Ring I did it
two different weight classes I did it at
my way Cruiserweight and then
heavyweight
and I won it three times so I did that
cruise away twice and I went up to
heavyweight once and I won it as well so
just a little
just so you know know your history know
your history the more you know
[Music]
these are good so far I'm surprised I'm
still waiting for that [ __ ]
okay it's crunchy mm-hmm
hmm she's a squatter
Ed you saw that mm-hmm
[Music]
this is Asian fusion yep
I can taste it I live in China for a bit
I'm not trying to smell
bringing you back what does your
research do you do your research okay
[Music]
you said
did you get hired or did you set this
whole thing up so where's Chris Chris is
the who's who created the show Chris
right there hi Chris good job but
anyways he was looking for somebody to
host it ask me about it and like just
the way he was like well what if we
interview celebrities but have them eat
increasingly spicy chicken wings over
the course of the interview as a way to
break it down genius and that was like a
Cupid's arrow into my brain yeah fell in
love with it and here we are eight years
later is he season 19 doing this [ __ ]
yeah and that's what I'm saying I'm just
glad to be finally here because when we
did it on
the whole thing interviewing someone and
making them feel uncomfortable that you
get the best content out of that this I
think it's all it's all kind of based
off this because you have even Colder's
balls Kevin Hart yeah yeah that's cool
as well yeah but yeah this I think
accepted all that yeah yeah well thank
you for saying that I appreciate that
and then let me uh pass a compliment to
you is you can kind of do whatever you
want like you have like actually good
YouTube channel you know like you have
like an actually good YouTube channel
thank you shout out to my brother David
freestyle bender on YouTube check it out
get that Vlog get that plug all right
Izzy we have a recurring segment on our
show called explain that gram we're
doing deep dive on our guest Instagram
full interesting pictures that need more
context all right so we'll pull the
picture up over here on the monitor you
just tell us the bigger story
[Music]
what is the significance of the world
and is there one in your storied career
of walk-offs there's the best one by
Fall classic okay so I explained the
story
this show was UFC 243 in Melbourne
Australia
it's my second time about to fight a
Melbourne because the first time was
Anderson yeah
and then um
the first time when I find Anderson I
remember I told Dana like I want to do a
you know something for a walk on Dana
was like nah you know he's not really
about that kind of [ __ ] and I was like
whatever then because Robert was meant
to headline that show I ended up
headlining it because he called in sick
and then when it was this time it was me
versus Robert I was like
my show
it's my time
57 127 people biggest attendance to date
so I came out to this track hyped to
Hype came out with my boys who was
getting book and it was just it just set
the tone because I walked into that that
stage that Arena into the Octagon like a
king I felt like a God I just and what
did I do I went in there showed off and
I showed out and closed the show in a
beautiful way and not defending my title
for the first time
[Music]
[ __ ] I literally just got chills
where my family moved to New Zealand
right
um I've always said this and I've said
this at nauseam was part of my story I
didn't really realize being black was a
problem until I moved
into a Western Country in the western
world
and people made me feel different for my
skin color because I I see white people
in my ear all the time I never I was
always just fascinated like oh that's
cool I'll look at your hair you know
like just you're amazed so some people
will like that at school with me they're
like wow you know you've got cool hair
you know but most people were not they
were just either
because I think it's taught racism is
taught someone it was weird but Nana was
one of the first people to invite my
family into her home so this is the
first time me seeing her in um I think
over 18 years she's still with it bro
she still lives by herself she gets
checked on her stuff but she's always
just
she'll wink at you and give you real
quick quips and she watches the fights
so Nana I'm okay mwah
um I should ask your car
but um yeah uh she's all there with her
her team of old ladies and they sit
there and they watch the UFC when I
fight yeah love that yeah all right are
you ready to move on here to the back
half you're doing great I'm waiting for
the [ __ ] [ __ ]
I think it might happen here but maybe
not let's see
turmeric bomb like I see a bit so this
is like it's not really oh my God I'm
gonna die but I can start to feel like
the
it's getting moist a little bit yeah
this is like some physiological effects
yes
responding yes
so you're affection for anime has been a
theme throughout your career from Death
Note references in the Octagon to even
your avatar inspired style Bender
nickname yeah how would you say being a
weeaboo has most served you as a mixed
martial artist
in so many different ways has just
helped me tell my own story be the
protagonist in my own story
the player one in my game
like right now okay I've already seen
the the setup for my next storyline the
hunter becomes a hunted and certain
characters and animes as well I draw
inspiration from like when Guy sensei
who's Rock Lee's uh Master when he
opened the eight gate they had a whole
like I think maybe two episodes telling
his backstory and when he finally opened
the eighth gate and he's standing there
and he's just red and got the flame and
mother is in front of him at the great
ninja war I cried actually when that
moment happened but it was yeah it was
just inspiring and people say oh
Route 33 oh [ __ ] hell you
still trying to rap shut up yeah
[Music]
I'm still waiting for the PIN to drop
ready
that's it yeah
uh what's the best how are you feeling
though so this is where it kind of
changes for me it's like right now my
tongue is a little bit on fire my lips
are numb lips aren't numb but my tongue
just caught away for that yeah so I
think what happens is it's like I know
what to expect same with you probably
right you know because like you've
already been there you know so that's
what I think ends up happening is like I
know what to expect so I'm never
panicking yeah but I'm also no superhero
so I'm feeling this [ __ ]
[ __ ] psycho
Financial advice you've ever gotten from
your father you know it's not every day
that a big money athlete has the benefit
of being raised by an accountant yeah
I'm stubborn so when I was young he was
trying to get me to I got to get the
milk yep I'm going in I was waiting for
you you know Cheers Cheers thanks for
having me man of course thank you
[Music]
I have sweet milk that's actually
delicious um when I came back from China
I tried to get me to get a house I'm
like oh I don't want the responsibility
of owning a house and blah blah blah I'm
too young
stupid lost a lot of money
eventually when I go to the UFC
I was like every time I don't listen to
this man about money
I end up going broke
listen to this man
I listen to my gut as well and each
every the Box off with me put it that
way but um yeah I listened to him when
it comes to money because he he knows
how money works
[Music]
[ __ ] me double
ready ready
I think this is where it starts to ah
yeah
this is a different yeah
um
[Music]
my precious
you gotta feel it don't fight it no
he's rolling it
oh yeah yeah
so people that are watching this on
Thanksgiving are probably just hours
away from sitting down with a turkey
macaroni and cheese stuffing family
beans when you think about a proper
Nigerian Feast what are some of the
non-negotiable dishes that have to be on
your table at the adasanya function oh
jollof rice standard
so Nigerian Foods
gargle a little bit
smart
there's levels today oh that's better
so um like you have the swallows which
are like the
it's like a doughy type
element
so you might have EBA which is made from
corn maze you have Amala a pound of yam
Fufu
symbol different types
if you use those you break it off
and put it in a different type of Stew
you can have a full re-roll
on Bono fried stew goat meat stew
anything and then you
I feel like this is a thing eating with
your hands is different
because we've lost our relationship with
food yeah I'll eat this at a restaurant
they'll give me [ __ ] knife I'm like
the [ __ ] four
what you want me to do with this
this is your hands
I'm the guy Nobu I'll be eating and I'd
like
I don't give a [ __ ] tantalizing
my great guy you're correct guy who told
you tantalizing you did when oh that's
right
quick recall I like that I like that
um
tantalizing I guess since my God you get
sense see now my nose is dribbling
oh man
I declare sinuses
oh I can smell everything
[Music]
will peaceful
the pain is a state of mind
it only affects you if you let it
so someone who grew up inspired by
Shaolin Monks and Bruce Lee is there a
film that you think best encapsulates
the experience of being a fighter
so ungbok was a movie I watched right
that's a movie that I feel like made
Muay Thai mainstream to the world excuse
me
let's do like a whole segment with all
my burps just like
rapid fire yeah he's already given us
our social Clips you're welcome
um one of my friends the the Drunken
Master Jackie Chan that was a good one
yeah yeah classic funny his movies was
just like excite me because he he just
seemed like he didn't want to fight or
he's having fun doing it yeah he's
really like funny like his fight scenes
are like funny exactly like it invokes
just the right emotion out of me it's
like I don't want to hurt anymore no
leave me alone
[Music]
no I'm so sorry
it's crazy and he did all his own stunts
most of them he was Tom Cruise before
Tom Cruise
so what we have to do close things out
take one thing a spicy Turkey Leg for
Thanksgiving
freshly open no fugazi no Fugazi
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
I'll join you at the party over here
I'll use let me see I'll use on this
drumstick how smart I was like gonna be
like how are we gonna do this
last time my first rodeo
I'm telling you I'm from Lagos we're
very Innovative over there
just don't open your emails if you get
it from a Nigerian president I'm joking
ready
oh bam
ah it's hot okay well the temperature
yeah both huh
[Music]
it's actually a really nice truck yeah
it's actually like a delicious dirt
right here
celebrating Thanksgiving how's the bone
the hot ones way is only we can
and here we are at the end of our spice
road closing out another Thanksgiving
special as your fans know you're an
incredible and undeniable Talent you're
pretty crazy yourself Izzy by the way I
am
but I was interested to learn that if it
wasn't for fighting maybe it would have
been a graphic designer and after your
post fight career I've heard you dream
about opening up an animation studio
yeah so I know that this puts you on the
spot a little bit but we would be so
adored I'll do it if you could give us a
commemorative
[Music]
on hot ones okay
two seconds away to the side I'll put it
right here
give me like five minutes sure take your
time
[Music]
music
player won your own game yeah
exactly
I wanted to use there's a stain on the
thing
I like yeah I like that there's that
stain though you know yeah I'm gonna use
it as a
as a template
something nice oh yes there it is
[Music]
came to me sometimes you just have to
let the
let the universe tell you what to do
I'll leave it at that it's a quick
little sketch I can't wait to oh
not sure what I was expecting but this
is amazing it's like we have the uh Pico
cat but I must
to a full-blown Thanksgiving turkey and
look at you Israel out of Sanya taking
on the hot ones Gauntlet body in it like
a Thanksgiving feast and then giving us
a masterpiece to Forever hang in the
museum of Curiosities and now there's
nothing left to do but roll out the red
carpet for you this camera this camera
this camera let the people know what you
have going on in your life now for the
first time in a long time I'm going to
enjoy Christmas for my family properly
all of us together and New Year's
actually celebrate with a whole
countdown and everything
and pretty much just enjoy life it's
more to life than fighting I love this
game I'm still a Savage in this Beast
I'm coming back for everything like I
said the hunter becomes a hunted but you
have to enjoy life because there's more
to life than fighting and there's more
to life than whatever you're doing so
yeah right now it's time to smell the
roses
and then eventually the warrior will get
back in the garden
thank you
[Applause]
so good
Let It Go no I won't you did so good
thank you this is going to be you had a
good time yeah [ __ ] yeah man you made it
so easy oh you got Savage and my
tongue's not burning anymore we cared we
fixed it we fixed it easy I'll take a
picture of this
hey what's going on hot ones fans thank
you so much for watching today's episode
and I have an important announcement to
all the mini spice Lords out there and
those of us who like to just dabble on
the fringes of spiced them say hello to
our newest flavor from hot ones Jr it's
the red the red takes things up a notch
with ghost pepper and red carrot it
brings a warming Zing to all of your
favorite foods try it on gooey mac and
cheese this winter and thank me later to
get your hands on the hot ones junior
family of sauces visit heatness.com
that's heatness.com heatness.com red
light yellow light green light go now